you said you wanted us to rejuvenate the
wilderness and the old school team have
listened mod Matt K is here to give us a
rundown on what's going to draw you back
to the pka's playground the wilderness
was dark and it was dangerous but the
wilderness was empty there's nobody in
it and there's nobody to kill in it of
course the players came to us and said
that's not good enough we need to change
that and the players came to us with a
whole load of ideas which we're now
going in game we've got a whole load of
stuff that players are gonna absolutely
love the whole idea behind it is to get
people into the wilderness and really
revitalize PvP in all school let's start
with the bosses we've got six of them
three of them are going to be
multiplayer bosses so you're going to
need to get your friends in to kill them
my favorite is probably the spider one
we're going to put that in a
single-player area so the only one
player can start the combat on it and
you've got to lure it into the multi-way
combat area so you can continue killing
it we've got the bear going in as well
we've got this skeletal warlord all of
which you're gonna need to bring your
friends for of course if they're not
really your friends they might try and
kill you instead which is half the fun
of it we've also got the chaos fanatic
we've got the crazed archaeologist and
we've got the queen scorpion all of
which will drop a third of a special new
shield which were putting into game
one of the things that players came to
us and said was the monsters in the
wilderness they're all right but they're
not particularly danger it's an
opportunity high level so we've put in
some high level versions of the monsters
are already in there they're gonna have
better dropped a ball so there's gonna
be better and Ward's to those who want
to risk more in there we've got the
dragon pickaxe going in which is gonna
be particularly useful in the resource
area right to the north of the
wilderness because the monsters in there
are weak to your mining level so not
just look at you combat levels to fight
them it's also your mining that all and
the dragon pickers will have a special
attack to make a wining level even
better
I made shield going in we've got a rain
shield going in both which can be
particularly useful especially if you're
going down to Dagon off Kings they're
some mid-level items so there's gonna be
a lot of demand for those one great idea
our players had was the room fountain
and it's a big obelisk that sticks in
the wilderness and it allows you to cast
any magic spell that you're able to cast
but without using any runes so for
example you've got a pile of new Long's
that you want to out you don't have the
runes to do it you can just hightail it
up into the wilderness and try Alcon um
before a Pico spots you and tries to
take your gold and your loot away from
you another great idea players had was a
PvP God Wars dungeon you can go in there
and you can kill the advances for
example the difference between this
dungeon and the non PvP one is that the
advantage will start dropping and noted
adamant bars so you can grind in there
and you can get some good loot in there
but every time you're in there a player
might come along and kill you and then
take all your stuff away from you so
it's gonna be a great resource for
making yourself rich but of course
there's gonna be the risk in there as
well
the wilderness is all about high-risk
and high-reward with all the new updates
going in there's going to be loads more
players on the 13th of March all these
ideas will be in game you guys need to
be there June in next month for more old
school news and if you enjoyed this
video remember to Like share and
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything runescape